il y a un mois Sophie Métadier apprend
que sa commune a été sélectionnée ça
vous a étonné ah oui totalement c'est
plutôt surprenant de recevoir un coup de
fil vous annonçant que vous êtes
sélectionné pour faire partie de cette
émission pour madame le Maire le village
préféré des Français et donc une aubaine
ça tombe bien
Beaulieu-lès-Loches 1800 habitants à des
atouts le plus prestigieux c'est le
grand clocher très clairement c'est
vraiment ce monument son patrimoine bâti
qui est extrêmement important avec
beaucoup d'édifices qui sont classés et
inscrits et puis ce qui fait aussi son
charme c'est ses habitants les
associations la dynamique qu'on retrouve
autour de ces artisans artisans d'art
artisans et entreprises
pour cette galerie située au cœur de la
commune c'est un coup de projecteur
apprécié il y a peu de commerce dans nos
petits villages et puis Beaulieu est un
peu décalé par rapport à
Loches donc petit à petit ça fait venir
un petit peu de monde pour pas que
visiter mais aussi voir quelque chose de
nouveau et le côté culturel est propre à
vos lieux le secret était bien gardé
dans ce restaurant personne ne
connaissait la nouvelle
victoire vous venez de me la prendre
comme quoi on allait participer à cette
émission là mais on ne savait pas du
tout encore et vous en pensez quoi ben
je pense que c'est très bien est-ce que
c'est un très beau village et puis en
étant restaurateur au contraire ça va
amener pas mal de gens à connaître cette
belle région
et puis on s'appelle Beaulieu donc
automatiquement cette un beau lieu le
tournage débutera mi-avril d'ici là vous
avez jusqu'au 10 mars pour voter pour
que Beaulieu-lès-Loches dev pourquoi pas
le village préféré des Français